my name is Jeff Gabe I'm 52 years old
and I run heavy equipment I was born
with it I've always been big all my life
she's always out there yelling for me
[Applause]
people are amazed that I don't really
train or work out there's a lot of guys
that spend hours in the gyms every day
to get where they're at
Porsche I'm lucky enough to be strong
enough to get there with strength we're
not all made in God's image the guy
caught somewhere in between Bruce Banner
and the hawk is Jeff and he's the
current North American armwrestling
champion in the left hand division
doctors can't figure out what's wrong
with him
but I'm pretty sure it's cancer because
his hand is way bigger than his face or
maybe someone his family tree had
unprotected sex with Donkey Kong but for
real is probably cancer good luck
looking up a second opinion on WebMD
with those bratwurst fingers his hobbies
include flicking a paper football at
country mile riding an ox around the
Minnesota State Fair and being a hand
model for Hamburger Helper
it's not all positive he's the reason
the men's room is always out of paper
towels he has to start every sentence
with fee fie foe fum and he paralyzes
chicks from the waist down every time he
slides his fingers in the second base so
one of his left arm is bigger than his
right Tom Cruise has one big tooth in
the middle of his stupid Scientology
mouth but I just wanted to talk to this
monster before torch-wielding mob gets
him that's why I flew him to LA where
I'm sure he got the arm rest in this
week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
[Music]
easy rampage just shoot me a text next
time you get here so I wrote that thanks
for inviting me over for tea did you
have a seat hope you're hungry
[Music]
so what's life like with these huge
pythons oh it's not different they work
good for everything there's nothing I
can't do
really you could pick up a dime off a
table yes on your first attempt well
when did your arms start getting big I
was born this way
it's just stay the same as I grew up now
is it just the arms nope I have one leg
in foot that's bigger than the other one
so your shoes are different sizes yes oh
my cashew xvii in my right foot it's a
10 from your left it's a legitimate
discrepancy between the two mm-hmm
testicles same size or there might be a
little variation but you've said you've
been tested and they said medically they
don't know what's going on now I think
your doctors are awful
they've got to figure something out and
say oh there's a reason that your arm is
this big the stuff they use you know
blood tests for I've tested up and don't
show any side do you want to come see
one of my fancy Beverly Hills doctors I
was do you ever have a sit-down talk
with your mother and say hey what was
going on so I think my motto is that she
had fallen when she was pregnant she
thought maybe I could do it and they
said no that's a crazy fall Oh get clip
your fingernails with toenail clippers
yes you do why I use a bigger ones
easier to hold onto oh you're in
physical pain no no pain can I hear how
loud you can clap sure sure no it sounds
just like any other planet have you ever
broken a bone in your body
no oh boy your pinky burger your one
finger that's taking on the earth
they're always Elliot I wouldn't know if
there was something in the way I was
born what's your biggest finger it's
your ring finger my ring finger yeah the
thumbs not that big
no this thumb is bigger than that I just
learned that about six months ago I mean
you just learn it six months ago you
weren't looking at your hands no how
strong was the the ring bear at your
wedding having to lug that thing down
the aisle
can you take it off yeah oh man that's a
napkin holder 30 how long have you been
married six years we've been together 20
years oh why are you dragging your feet
so long because one of them's a size 16
what about at night does your wife like
to be spooned or coddled that's because
I assume if that monster goes over her
cutting off some circulation now if we
have a king bed
keeping playing a winged room okay so
you don't drape one of those things over
no our guys more fascinated by you that
or is it women it's probably men I said
more guys I bet your penis was terrified
the first time you tried to masturbate
as a child when they do say hands have a
direct correlation to the to the size of
a penis can you put that myth to bed say
yes everything's properly proportioned
but that's not properly proportioned 5:9
are you really yeah yeah any fella yes
it sure your tiny fella God really
doesn't deal with both hands no do you
ever do this is a kid hey put your hands
together and you open up the here is the
church here is the steeple open it up
and Oh God what are the odds that you'd
be blessed with these massive arms and
you're good at armless and because
there's technique in our live technique
yeah why are you always arm-wrestle and
left-handed I hurt my right one in the
80s I'm wrestling there's no way I can
compete with it now is the left-handed
competition is that right below the
women's class where is where's the less
just above it are you right-handed yes
so are you technically at a disadvantage
because it's not your dominant hand know
which arms bigger for left I mean I
guess talk to me about how the movie
over-the-top changed your life Kelly I
got we're a short is more technique in
it uh-huh
than just the power I arm wrestled the
kid from that movie well know how it
went I was kind of sandbagging I was
like I'm gonna snap him whenever I feel
like it and then I hit a wall and I lost
it and he beat me so my last match was
lost but it was to that kid so I feel
like it was that's okay still then in
the armrest are you you're the world
champion no I'm not world I have the
North American Championship belt right
now
can I see your belt oh this is
impressive
a lot heavier than I thought do you ever
wear this I wore it on the plane there
and then they bring it here you wore it
on the plane yes no you did this I did
TSA didn't stop you for this March took
it up and sent it to them Rebecca is
insane I appreciate it
she's a beaut thanks for coming over
Jeff I'd really like to keep in touch
sure would you like to be best friends
huh I mean my dogs my best friend but
he's under that door so sure
[Applause]
[Music]
guess I'm wearing your shirt there
now according to my uncle a big part of
being best friends is checking each
other's prostate
don't be weird about this all right if
you say so yeah here try this ash is Old
Faithful is the heaviest thing I carry
around is the guilt of never using my
pellet on bike
you